Okay, let's talk about PyMongo. Now PyMongo is one of the
MongoDB drivers. Or client libraries. And because Python is the programming
language for this course, we'll be using the Python driver. You'll
find that you have access to PyMongo in the IDE. Now one
thing to keep in mind about PyMongo or any other MongoDB
driver is that, their basic job is to maintain a connection to
the database and to allow you to work in your language
of choice and interact with your data in a very natural way.
Now if you'd like to know about drivers for other languages
I'd encourage you to visit api.mongodb.org where you can read about
all supported drivers. Now before we dive in and look at
an example I want to talk a little bit about the application
architecture, just so you have that picture in your mind as
we're working through the rest of the material in this lesson.
Okay, so if you download MongoDB and run it on your
local computer This picture basically represents
the architecture. You'll start Mongo DB,
and the demon that's running is Mongo D.
And then you'll create a Python application that includes
the PyMongo module. And using the PyMongo module,
you can send requests, and receive responses from Mongo
DB. PyMongo communicates with the database using what
we call the wire protocol, and the data that's
exchanged is in a format we call BSON.
BSON is a binary encoding for JSON. If you
Google for BSON, you'll easily find the spec.
Okay, so let's look at an app. Okay. Here
I'm going to use that example that we say
before for the Tesla S but let's talk about
the PyMongo components of this particular application. Here
we're inputting the MongoClient class from the pymongo module.
And then we're going to create a client object
and note that here, we specify the connection string.
We won't go into too much detail into this but
essentially this will allow us to connect to Any MongoD
instance that we have access to. Okay, here's the encoding
of the Tesla as a Python dictionary, and then here what
we're doing is specifying that we want to use the examples
database, and what we want to do here is insert this document
here. Finally, we're going to do a find query, and
then for every document that we get back We're simply going
to print that document out. Okay, now before we run
this, I want to point out two things, one is that
we're using the insert command in order to store this
document in the autos collection for the examples database. Here
we're using the find command, and find, when run this
way, will simply give us back a cursor for all
of the documents in, in this case, the autos collection.
Whatever collection we specify here. Okay? And we'll go into more
detail on these, later on in this lesson. So, let's run this.
Okay, and we can see that what we got back and printed
out was the one and only document that we had inserted into this
collection. Brand new collection. When we inserted the document, that became the
first document in the collection. And one thing I want to point out
is that in addition to all of the fields we specified in
our code, there is a new field, underscore ID that has this object
ID value. Okay? That's a value that was added by the database
and we'll talk a little bit later about exactly what this value represents.
The short story is that MongoDB ensures that any
document we insert can be uniquely identified by it's
underscore id field. And if we don't specify a
value for underscore id, mongoDB will create one for us.